[Music]
so
so
do
good afternoon everybody
first i want to thank president biden
and vice president harris for hosting
this event here at the white house
making clear that trucking is indeed a
national priority
and i want to thank everyone here
especially the truck drivers and
transportation workers we count on so
much
i have to share this is a big day in my
own household because it was our first
time taking our kids to daycare
and
as i was getting ready for that because
i knew this event was coming up i kept
looking around at all of the physical
items that surrounded us and thought
about how they got here the bottles the
little jars of baby food the spoons we
were using to feed them the high chairs
they were sitting in
even the family minivan itself
got to us because truck drivers brought
them to where they needed to be
and that's true for everything that we
count on groceries books
livestock medicine
if you enjoyed the food you ate for
breakfast the clothes that you're
wearing right now or the device you
might be using to watch this event you
can thank a truck driver for getting
that to you
and that's what makes this trucking
action plan so important plus this fits
two central priorities that the
president has laid out addressing supply
chain disruptions to lower costs for
families and getting workers the pay and
the respect that they deserve
over the last two years we've all been
using terms like supply chain and
essential worker more than we used to
in fact there's nothing new about how
much america counts on truckers but it
has become more urgent than ever
right now the industry estimates that
we're short 80 000 truck drivers
and my department estimates that 300 000
leave the career every year so we must
do more and do better to recruit more
people into the job
and to support them so they choose to
stay in the job
and that's more than saying thank you it
is concrete specific actions to help our
trucking workforce thrive in this career
to make sure the trucking jobs are as
high quality as safe and as well paid as
they ought to be and that is what
president biden challenged us to do with
this trucking action plan so we started
out by going and listening to truck
drivers virtually and in person we
talked to truck drivers in every part of
the country as part of that i got to
spend some time on the road and the
passenger seat of a semi with a driver
in illinois named lola who i think is
here today there you are hey good seeing
you
and she brought her granddaughter lola
ann who she talked about a lot i'm glad
i actually got to meet you she talked
about her family she talked about
wanting to be a driver for years but
waiting till her kids were grown so she
could start going over the road we
talked about safety talk about training
about why she loves this job and how we
could make it easier and that day and
across all the conversations i saw the
pride truckers take in their work and
the challenges they face
their voices have shaped the work we
took up in the president's trucking
action plan
and we just completed the 90-day sprint
to get these actions off the ground so
i'm pleased to provide an update
in order to create debt-free pathways
into the career for more people
including more women and drivers of
color we teamed up with the department
of labor to grow the number of
registered apprenticeships for high
quality paid on-the-job training we're
investigating truck leasing arrangements
to make sure that they're above board
we're working on truck driver pay
including those hours when drivers don't
get paid even though they're very much
on the job because they're waiting for
somebody else
we're making it easier for veterans to
join the trucking workforce partnering
with the department of defense and of
course we are fixing roads and bridges
across america
one trucker told me infrastructure is
our workplace and now we are enhancing
that workplace thanks to unprecedented
funding through the president's
infrastructure law
and yes that includes working with
states to use that funding to build more
safe truck parking because we know that
that is such a central issue for
truckers today
these actions are going to help us
recruit more drivers and just as
importantly retain them
to help keep down shipping delays rein
in the price of goods at a time when
we're fighting inflation with everything
we've got and of course supporting these
essential workers is just the right
thing to do
i'm proud of all we got done in this
90-day sprint
but i promise you to the trucking
community and i promise you mr president
this is just the beginning we're going
to keep our foot on the gas to deliver
for the drivers who deliver for us every
single day and you're going to hear more
about that shortly but now it's my
pleasure to hand it over to a good
friend a proud army veteran an
entrepreneur who served as a u.s
congressman acting secretary of the army
and chair of a new veterans task force
patrick murphy secretary murphy
[Applause]
thank you secretary mr president and
maria uh it is great to be here i just
want to just begin by saying thank you
to secretary but a judge um
for our brother and sister veterans uh
he is truly one of the leading voices of
the 9 11 generation so consider i thank
you for your leadership and that
introduction and i also want to thank
the white house national economic
council uh for doing
phenomenal work around task force
movement which we're here today to
discuss and launch
um
you know when you look at
the secretary mentioned uh low land over
there lola is eight years old i try to
get her to say go army
beat navy she comes from a navy family
jada next to her is ready to say she's
six jade is ready to say it but mr
president i know you asked for a
non-partisan event so i'm not allowed to
say that but i apologize for good luck
going off scripts um
meet a secretary it's reverse navy but
we're all brothers and sisters
in that profession and that profession
is incredibly important to the trucking
industry
in fact that's a
industry that my grandfather when he
came back from the navy world war ii in
the pacific came back and was a trucker
with the teamsters 107.
in philadelphia
and they drove for a p supermarkets and
then my dad came back from the navy
he also
joined and was a trucker but first was a
police officer in philadelphia but on
the sides to make ends meet
went in the trucking on the weekends
and i remember going down i-95 with him
in that cab
uh it's incredibly important
and
what test
force movement is all about
is really to create that bridge
that bridge between veterans and the
trucking industry because for my family
it was built
and survived on in that industry it's
how we got through
and i will tell you it's that bridge
that needs to be more accessible to our
brother and sister veterans
it is that bridge that needs to make
sure we launch this
and make it happen for the next
generation of truckers whether it's lola
or jada
in the crowd
and that's what today's announcement's
about
that is what this work will be for
uh
and i will tell you when
mayor peter sorry secretary pete
i came back from afghanistan when i came
back from iraq you know we committed
ourselves to public service we committed
to be there for our brothers and sisters
to make sure that although we made it
home we need to make sure our generation
has the opportunities to succeed in life
and
we committed ourselves to that and
that's what this
task force will do
it's about opportunity
it's about the future of america
it's about making sure america gets back
to work and
today
is a proud moment
but today is just the beginning to
continue what you've already established
not just here in the white house not
just the department of transportation
but all across america the numbers will
speak for themselves
but
it is that burden that sacred burden for
those of us who have been
overseas
to make sure that we give back and make
it better for the next generation
for the lolas and the jadas
it's my honor now to introduce
one of the faces
of american infrastructure
one of the faces that are out there in
these type of cabs out there making
things happen and that's maria rodriguez
so please give it up to our next speaker
maria rodriguez
thank you
hi good afternoon
my name is maria rodriguez and i am very
honored to be here today i'm currently
an apprentice truck driver at nfi
my road to get to this point was very
unique
i came to the united states with my
parents from venezuela at a very young
age of two
my family came here looking for a better
life and to live the american dream
i always admired their hard work
dedication and sacrifices even when
times were tough
they kept driving forward
from an early age i was inspired by
watching my father cook
he would make masterpieces out of a few
ingredients and be able to bring so much
joy and happiness through his food i
knew i wanted to do the same and be a
chef someday
when i was old enough i began to work as
a server in a very small restaurant
as time went on i worked for
so many amazing restaurants but in march
of 2020 i was laid off due to the covet
pandemic
at the time i was also a new mom and
worried about how i would support my
family
i knew i had to make a career change
at first i attended school to be an emt
with hopes of being a firefighter but
ultimately the training made it
difficult for me to also support my
family
my significant other abel and our son
and i live two minutes away from new
england tractor trailer training school
better known as nets
we also would always watch these big 18
wheelers drive by our house
for months i encouraged abel to call
them
so he could enroll since he was also
looking for a fresh start
nets gave him an equal opportunity and
his passion for the industry grew
he convinced me to attend as well
i was a bit intimidated in a
male-dominated field but i immediately
felt comfortable at nets
and throughout our training different
companies would come speak about their
opportunities
nfi stuck
stuck out from day one with their core
family value and local routes
wear your home every day
my family and home time
are everything to me so i knew nfi would
be my top choice
and if i also offered the apprenticeship
opportunity where once i was hired i
received hands-on training and
mentorship all while being paid while i
continued to learn
upon graduation i applied to nfi
and worked with a local recruiter his
name is craig
who also made the application to the
apprenticeship extremely easy i signed
on with nfi and soon after abel did too
abel and i went to school together we
graduated together and now we're working
and training together
i couldn't have done it without his
encouragement and support and i'm so
happy that we did this together
as a
thank you
as i continue my apprenticeship
i love my i love that my schedule is
very consistent and i get home before my
son finishes school
through our new careers we found a place
where we can be financially stable
the trucking industry is in high demand
and there are jobs here that can support
our family
as an essential part of the supply chain
i feel like i'm a part of something
bigger than myself which is very
rewarding
i want to thank president biden and vice
president president harris for leading
the 1990 day trucking apprenticeship
program
this program has built clear paths to
careers in truck driving that are
fulfilling and offer endless
opportunities
i feel like i leaped into this new
career and i'm so happy that i did
i hope that i can be an inspiration to
other women
who are thinking of joining the industry
i struggled to find a career
but i didn't give up
and now i'm a successful mom
daughter
friend and truck driver
now it is my great honor to introduce a
president
who has done more for truckers in three
months
than other presidents have in four years
a man who has put workers first
his entire life and at the center of
this administration
president joe biden
thank you
great job
i think she can do anything she wants
don't you
well hello everyone it's an honor to
welcome you to the white house out on
the lawn here i heard that helicopter
going by i was hoping the hell wasn't
going to land
maria thanks for sharing your story and
my buddy patrick murphy
former assistant secretary uh secretary
of the army as well as uh former
congressman
and uh
the boy stays in shape man look at him
i uh
and uh i want to thank you for being
here man
nobody worked harder as a congressman or
acting secretary of the army to connect
veterans opportunity and that's what's
all been all about for you and i want to
thank
another veteran who knows a thing or two
about laying the foundation for good
jobs and
transportation sector secretary bootages
and i he says go navy he says go army
i used to say go navy
but then my son got a bronze star in the
army and i decided i couldn't say it
anymore
so i i just said go american forces
anyway
also honor i recognize he couldn't be
here today but marty walsh the secretary
of the uh of labor and he's doing an
outstanding job helping to lead this
effort alongside pete
secretary budapest and you know i want
to welcome members of congress are here
today as well
tammy how are you tammy good to see you
tammy baldwin by the way
and also congressman pete defazio
and laura underwood where's laura there
she is right there right in front good
to see you laura
and i want to
that particular shout out to the new
president of the teamsters sean o'brien
stand up man i want to see you
as
as they say
parts of wilmington delaware these guys
brung me to the dance 35 years ago 40
years ago and also i want to say a quick
eye to a pal
uh and you've been a pal uh you know i
thank you for being here and getting
things done
and you know uh in addition to all that
there's an outfit uh called you probably
heard them united mine workers
yeah well you know they got the
president here too mr president where
are you
where's he sitting he was here
a lot of truckers united my workers
at any rate
folks i spent a lot of time talking
about the economy and the
record-breaking economic comeback were
experienced because of all of you
sitting out there in those chairs
today i want to talk with people who are
who are making the comeback possible
people like maria who you just heard
from and her son roman who's gone pretty
soon and uh and all those truck drivers
and their families here today i want to
thank you all
uh to uh you know keep what you're doing
to keep america moving because that's
literally what you're doing especially
these last two years helping carry the
nation literally on your backs you've
learned on friday the economy created
431 000 jobs in march
a record
over the course of my presidency the
economy has now created 7.9 million jobs
more jobs in the first 14 months than
any president ever in large part because
of all of you not a joke
unemployment's at 3.6 percent down from
6.4 when we took office the fastest
decline in unemployment start of any
presidential term ever recorded
and after a long stretch
americans are back to work americans are
back to work and economy has gone from
being on the mend to being on the move
in the economy we're building we're
building a strong economy one where
hard-working americans can live with
dignity support their families build a
better life and a better life for their
children as well
all of you here today are people our
economy should be built around because
you all you all are the people who
literally make it run that's not
hyperbole you literally make it run
i have nothing against investment
bankers they could all retire and
nothing much would change you all quit
everything comes to a halt think about
it i'm not joking
think about it come to a literal hall
during the pandemic a lot of americans
have been introduced to a term you all
know well and pete used it supply chains
a simple term
supply chain is a journey the journey of
a product to get to a customer's
doorstep that's what it is and during
the pandemic
those chains are interrupted factory
closures around the world not just the
united states around the world cause
backups and delays because of covet at
the same time
because of the strength and speed of our
recovery americans had more money in
their pockets than they had in a long
time
during the pandemic they wanted to spend
that money not on restaurants or
vacations which are now coming back as
well but on hard goods
they wanted home improvements
televisions automobiles things that had
to be transported the very products are
slowed down by disruption of the supply
chain
demand was high
supply was interrupted
the recipe for higher prices and long
delays that's exactly what we saw not
only here but all around the world
so we knew we needed every tool at our
disposal to address the problem and the
best way to do it was to invest in
people who make the supply chain run
trucking moves about 70 percent
about 70 percent of all the goods in
this country 70 percent and truck
drivers
are facing real challenges
the average driver waits four and a half
hours
for their truck to be loaded and
unloaded during an 11 hour shift
and 40 of their day
and often they don't get paid for that
wait time
back in 1978
the average truck drivers pay was 34
was 34
an hour in today's dollars last year it
was 25
an hour
nearly a 30 decline
in this iconic american industry it's
getting harder and harder to raise a
family with dignity and pride that you
deserve
it's no surprise
so many drivers left their jobs
the workforce is getting older
not that i am but they are
i used to drive a truck it's a long
story anyway
it's getting hard and i thought i was
going to get to drive one of these
suckers today
anyway it's another story too but look
it's getting harder and harder to
recruit new drivers particularly women
and people of color to an industry that
this nation and our economy desperately
needs at full strength
the good news is that since i took
office we've begun to turn things around
in fact in 2021 was the best year for
trucking employment since 1994.
there are now
35 000 more trucking jobs than there
were before the pandemic
but we all know we need to move faster
getting more people working in this
industry and jobs they can rely on and
raise a family on
that's why last december we brought
together industry and labor to tackle
the problem facing drivers and we
listened
and when we heard that there were long
wait times in many states for people to
get their commercial driver's license
their cdls we took action
we provided technical assistance as well
as 57 million dollars in federal funds
to help states issue these cdl is faster
and i'm proud to report because of pete
and others so far in 2022 we're issuing
cdls that double the rate of last year
120 000 in january and february alone
we also know that the key ingredient to
get into keeping more drivers was
increasing training programs like the
registered apprenticeships approved by
the department of labor
programs allow aspiring drivers to learn
while earned while they learn
while making this essential job more
attractive for potential drivers
regardless of age background and gender
the program has proven to be
improved safety
and better working conditions and better
pay and benefits typically it takes
about eight months to create a
registered apprenticeship program but
because of pete and others in this
department of labor were able to cut the
red tape and now it takes as little as
two days
as a result
in the last 90 days 100 major employers
have launched new registered
apprenticeship programs ups dominoes
pepsis albertsons and more along with
the trade association like the american
trucking association the national
minority trucking association the food
industry association and others
what that all adds up to
is a strong foundation for the work
ahead
a pipeline of hard-working men and women
from all backgrounds highly trained and
highly motivated to get behind the wheel
including a whole lot of veterans
thanks to the veterans trucking
initiative known as task force movement
by patrick murphy led by patrick murphy
and by the way i'd say parenthetically
if you can handle a tank if you can
handle an armored personnel carry you
sure and hell can handle one of these
suckers and an awful lot of well-known
people also the idea i remember i'm
going to digress for one second
i i got a commercial license because my
dad used to run an automobile agency and
i used to have to go up to the body shop
up in philadelphia from wilmington and
when they'd order a trailer or a cab i
just they'd sell the cab and so i had to
have a license to be able to drive it up
and back
and so during the trucker strike years
later when i was a young senator i was
there was a guy who
ran steel from deemer steele out to ohio
and so i decided to ride out with him
see what it was like on the strike and i
was driving going through shiloh ohio
and uh and he he was his handle was big
ten
and remember everybody all the truck
stops were being blockaded at the time
and during during the strike
and he uh he called he said big ten
wanting to come in i forget exactly how
he said it and the and the only woman
truck driver ever knew i met that day
she said this is big mama no room
swear to god true story
swear to god i've got a united states
senator driving my truck she said i got
the damn president of mine so what
i'll never forget that i was very
powerful guy anyway
that was the first woman trucker i met
but look the the labor and labor
transportation departments are working
closely with industry to tackle issues
facing women in trucking recruit and
retrain more women drivers so we can
draw more americans to work with
increased wages reduce wait times and
improve safety and so much more
folks there's a heck of a lot more we
have to do a lot more we have to do
secretary booted has laid out some of
the steps we're taking to make these
jobs more attractive for more americans
and it's all centered around listening
to you the drivers
look
you've got to keep it we've got to keep
it going
we're building a better economy around
american manufacturing and american
supply chains and thanks to the
infrastructure law and it wasn't my law
as a bipartisan one of the few great
bipartisan things we've done this year
we're making the largest investment in
american roads and bridges since
literally the creation of interstate
highway system
and that means a bright future for
american trucking
this this country will be counting on
you more than it ever has
so we should be able to you should be
able to count on us to keep investing in
you and your families that's exactly
what we're going to do i'm looking
forward to all the progress we're going
to make together i want to thank you all
thank you for being here thank you for
what you do thank your families and may
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops thank you thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
shut up
[Music]
lauren nice to meet you
[Music]
here
[Music]
huh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
we'll see where we go
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
um